hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in the second part of the ethics of
authenticity simone bevoir
is examining types or persons
who make an inauthentic use of their
human freedom and the fourth type
that she considers she calls the
adventurer
and the adventurer comes right after the
nihilist because they have
some things in common it's actually good
to read this little little paragraph
she is as she makes the transition she
says it's possible that even
in this failure of finding some
universal absolute end
a man may nevertheless keep his taste
for an existence which he originally
felt
as a joy hoping for no justification
he will nevertheless take delight in
living
he will seek a pretext for a gratuitous
display of
activity such a person is what we call
an adventurer
and she says he throws himself into his
undertakings with
zest and so what we have here is an aff
activity
that is very different than the the
other ones the nihilist was
saying oh we don't have any
pre-established values i can't really
trust anything
nothing matters there's kind of doom and
gloom with this
it's more yes nothing really matters i
can do whatever i want i can throw
myself
into anything that i like and so there's
there's
something attractive to this and she
actually at another point says that
it's close to a genuinely moral
attitude so there's a somewhat more
positive valorization of it but
there's still some central problems so
she says that this person
finds joy in spreading
a freedom that is indifferent to its
content she also says
the adventurer throws themselves into
action unattached to the end that is
aimed at that doesn't mean that they
don't have any ends
or purposes or goals but if they miss
them
not a problem we'll find another goal
the main thing is to keep on striving to
keep on doing
to keep on engaging to move from
conquest to conquest
or from retreat to retreat if that's
what has to happen
like she says he likes action for his or
for its own
sake whether this is based on nihilistic
despair or born directly from experience
of the happy days of childhood
it always implies freedom is realized as
an
independence in regard to the serious
world the world of the serious person
and the ambiguity of existence is felt
not as a lack but in its positive
aspects so she says this dialectically
envelops nihilism's opposition to the
serious
and the opposition to nihilism by
existence as such so
in a way this person is an ally of
existence they
embrace existence but they they don't
embrace existence in its totality
there's something that's going to be
missing as we see
so how is this close to a genuinely
moral attitude
or how is this close to ethics as
she says well she says the adventurer
does not propose to be he deliberately
makes himself a lack of being from an
existentialist perspective
that's a good thing they open themselves
up to possibilities right they don't
insist that i'm only this thing so
he says that engaged in undertaking he
is at the same time detached from the
goal
whether he succeeds or fails he goes
right ahead throwing himself into a new
enterprise
it's not from things he expects the
justification of his choices
considering such behavior at the moment
of its subjectivity she says
we see it conforms to the requirement of
ethics this sounds pretty good so far
and then she drops the the hammer she
says
uh here we go if existentialism were
solipsistic
now solipsistic means thinking that
you're the only
person who matters in the world you are
the center of existence if
existentialism really was that way
then the adventurer would be the sort of
uh
you know embodiment of existentialism
she's saying that's not the case
others the world of others actually
matters
and so you know the adventurer is not
the hero here
and she tells us a few things the first
is that the adventurer's attitude
is not always as pure and you know
carefree as it's pretended to be she
says behind the
appearance there are many men who pursue
a secret goal
in utter seriousness they proclaim their
skepticism
in regard to accepted values
or recognized values but they are
opportunistic
they are really after something and what
are the
examples that she gives she says that
there's an attachment to
some value of the serious by that
she means they are in fact taking
something seriously
and so we've got a lot of examples here
fortune right
glory uh reputation celebrity
success doing well careerism uh
pleasure she's got this great example
about don
juan if you don't know who don juan was
he was
a constant womanizer and he left behind
a whole bunch of conquests
in his wake and she says you know
don juan himself um
[Music]
you know the taste for conquest is often
subtly tied
up with the taste for possession was
seduction all that don juan liked did he
not also like women
or was he not even looking for a capable
a woman capable
of satisfying him it's possible to have
multiple goals
and to conceal from oneself that the
adventures that one is engaging in
seemingly in a free way are really
motivated by these these
other things there's a deeper problem
that would be a kind of self-deception
right here the deeper problem
is of not acknowledging one's relation
to
others in a world the adventurer
engages in undertakings as she says
that unfold in a human world
that affect other people so
there's two different options possible
when one runs into that she says
we can become conscious of the real
requirements of our own freedom
which will itself which can will itself
only by destiny itself to an open future
by seeking to extend itself
by means of the freedom of others
this is a central idea to bevoir's
concept of existentialism and
of of the genuinely ethical we have to
recognize that our
freedom is connected with the freedom of
others so if we're
using our freedom in such a way as to
make others
less free making ourselves the center of
existence the way the adventure often
does
we're not really fully realizing our own
freedom and she says we have to realize
the freedom of other people must be
respected
they must be helped to free themselves
such a law imposes limits on
action and at the same time gives it a
content so
beyond the rejected seriousness the
seriousness of the serious
person is found a genuine seriousness
and if you engage that you really can't
be the adventurer anymore
now there's there's you know
consequences now there's
conditions now there's commitments now
there's sacrifices that have to be made
on one's own part the other attitude is
that
of the adventurer who says i understand
others exist
but they really exist for you know
essentially like props
for me you can think of the adventurer
as somebody who views the world that
they're in
as something like a uh
you know a game in which everybody else
are
ultimately non-player characters or if
they are
other players they exist to be dominated
they exist to be manipulated they exist
to be used
they exist to be collaborated with so
long as it suits the adventurer
and they treat others as mere means
or as obstacles or they sacrifice them
and so
she gives some examples here the fate of
italy mattered very little to the
italian conde thierry that was these
mercenaries who were fighting
in italy but didn't really care about
who
actually won or not don juan was
unaffected by
elvira's tears the massacres of indians
mel
meant nothing to pizarro and she says
indifferent to the ends they set up for
themselves
they were more indifferent to the means
of attaining them they cared
only for their pleasure or their glory
and so the adventurer actually shares
the nihilist contempt for
other human beings it gets worse than
that
she points out that in order to enjoy
their freedom in order to
enjoy their capacity to do what it is
that they want to do
they will collaborate they will give in
they will submit themselves to those who
can provide
them the means that they need she says
he needs money arms soldiers or the
support of the police and the laws it's
not a matter of chance
but a dialectical necessity which leads
the adventurer to be complacent
regarding all regimes which defend the
privilege
of a class or party more particularly
authoritarian regimes and fascism
he needs fortune leisure and enjoyment
and will take these goods as supreme
ends
in order to be prepared to remain free
in regard to
any end so in order to hold on to their
ability to be a player to to play the
game
they will collaborate with those who are
depriving other human beings
of their freedom who are crushing other
human beings who are abusing them
and thereby become complicit even while
denying
their complicity in that and so that's
another problematic aspect of
adventurers
wait around long enough and you'll see
an adventure sooner or later fall into
that even if they're on the side of the
good guys
at first the side of human freedom all
it takes
is them to you know run into a difficult
situation
and they will go to the the other side
and so she says that somebody who's a
real lover of freedom won't trust an
adventurer there's also one other
important consideration here she talks
about the
essentially the legacy what remains
of the subjectivity of the adventurer
and she says that in their lifetime
they're trying to make everybody see
things their way they're aiming
they're trying to go towards a future
into recognition or
admiration when he dies the adventurer
will be surrendering his whole life into
the hands of men
the only meaning it will have will be
the one they confer
on it he knows since he talks he knows
this since he talks about himself
often in books and isn't this
interesting the way that she's
doing it they write memoirs about
themselves they try to
spin their their own legacy
it doesn't really work and
we might say that even more in our time
than in their own time you can't really
control
what other people are going to make of
you you could actually be a genuinely
good person
and be marked as a terrible person
by lies being spread about you but the
adventurer doesn't have to do that
they're usually going to be
kind of a selfish bastard anyway and
they're going to
have lied to other people about you know
why they did the things that they did
and put on a good face about it
and then sooner or later somebody's
going to cut through the lies
and say they were kind of a scumbag
weren't they they might have had a
nice face or a charming way of being or
put on the best parties
or did cool things but sooner or later
it's up to other people to make the
decision
history decides about them and so
they the in the end they don't actually
manage
to remain within what she called this
solipsism
this self-centered understanding of
freedom
and this is another defective way of
using one's freedom notice that there is
an out that's possible here where you
realize
that you exist in a world that has other
people that are
others just as much as uh you'd they're
just as human as you they have
freedom and there could be a different
response to that but the adventurer
doesn't take that route and instead
they go along with stressing their
freedom over
that of others
you